this is food supermarkets no longer want
to sell but Uber's hour is more than
happy to buy for 1 euro 50. it's the
only way he can put a nutritious meal on
the table the 60 year old pensioner says
with prices soaring it has become
impossible to live on his pension of 368
Euros a month am I being is good I find
I have less and less money but meanwhile
energy costs are going up I am really
struggling to make ends meet if
organizations like this would not exist
it would be a lot harder for me
after registering people can choose from
groceries that are about to expire that
have been collected from supermarkets
but recently some people had to be
rejected due to a lack of Supply the
people who are coming here within the
number of people increased extensively
and we had to stop new registrations we
can only give it to those who are
registered here who are here for a long
time
and the others well that's necessarily
the problem what can we do for them the
same goes for nearly 1 000 other food
banks in Germany
most people here are too embarrassed to
be filmed some told me they don't want
their colleagues to see them depending
on food handouts while this is one of
the world's richest countries inequality
has risen sharply in recent months now
people with jobs and steady incomes are
turning to these food banks for help
to help people cope with high inflation
and pay for their energy bills the
government has given relief payments to
all Germans but eight organizations say
more needs to be done
the government talks a lot but has to do
more we do this work without being paid
normally in a country like this it
should not be the case that we are the
ones helping these people for 13 euros
Hilda Hotel managed to buy enough
groceries to last for days for her this
weekly trip to the food bank is painful
because they don't give me enough of a
pension I'm being screwed over in this
country parliamentarians are getting 700
euros because of the high inflation and
what do we get 50 euros seriously that's
nothing it's terrible how they treat us
old people we've also worked hard for
this country
food banks expect even more customers
next year with prices not expecting to
go down soon and a possible recession
inside stop fast and Al Jazeera Berlin